this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
army's museum in the uk
which houses a collection of thousands
of iconic weapons from throughout
history and on this week's episode he's
taking a look at even more weapons from
team fortress 2
and in this process is slowly losing his
mind and then we have this thing
which is i swear this has been included
just to break my mind
there's no physical way that this thing
could work
if you want to see more of jonathan
reacting to team fortress 2 weapons make
sure to subscribe and check out the
previous video we made on valve's
classic shooter
and if you'd like to help out the royal
army's museum and continue to support
jonathan's work
check out the links in the description
of this video right
over to jonathan
okay of course there right here we are
again the short stop
uh short stop is actually a very apt
name for this
weapon the real version because it's
only really any use
at very close range now that's obviously
not the case
in the game this thing is reasonably
long ranged and
apparently absolutely devastating here
is one this
is the cop derringer which is a four
barrel 357 magnum slash 38 special
because you can fit whatever you can fit
in it you can shoot essentially
looks much like it does in the game it
works much like it does in the game
except you can't just flick it forward
you you have a catch on the top
to unlatch the barrel which feels a
little uninspiring and flimsy but is um
there's enough metal there to keep this
thing shut and interestingly the 3d
model for the game
does actually model this latch on the
top without the
ears on it for opening it up it's a
surprisingly accurate rendition of the
gun i think
the notable difference is that the gun
in the game has a whacking great hammer
modeled on the back of it although it
doesn't do anything because tf2
um whereas this is striker fired by that
horrific trigger
[Music]
[Applause]
right interesting name here pretty boy's
pocket pistol now
superficially this looks a bit like one
of the
kind of vest pocket pistols of the 1910s
20s
fm browning 1905 colt 1908
that kind of thing very very small
literally vest pocket pistols because
they fitted in a vest pocket
and the name pretty boy presumably
refers to pretty boy floyd who again is
a prohibition era
gangster who probably had one of those
vest pocket pistols but then when we
load into the game
the thing is immense that's probably a
joke that's probably a deliberate
in-joke that this is a pocket pistol but
we're gonna make it huge we've got a
bizarre reload where he flips it over
forwards
having ejected the magazine and slaps in
another one from the top and then flicks
it back round again
good luck doing that with an actual
1920s pocket pistol that's impossible
in fact they have even the ones with
button magazine releases
are the magazines don't drop free you
have to pull them out put another one in
but who cares it's team fortress
a bit of video gaming history here this
is something people in the comments
last time were alerting us to so this is
the rocket launcher from the original
quake
game this game does draw upon pretty
heavily so of course they put in
the actual weapon from quake and it's
even held in a
central position in the middle of the
bottom screen just like it was in quake
the early 3d graphics of quake don't
really lend themselves to detail but
this is
the same design but given some more
detail with those
weird exhaust vent things around the
muzzle
interestingly in the little character
picture on the bottom
left of the screen we we see him holding
it on his shoulder like a normal rocket
a normal
rocket launcher from team fortress but
um yeah in the actual first person view
it's where it should be for quake and
then of course
i think as i commented with the other
rocket launchers the rockets do have
that slow
vapor trail design to them so there's a
nice little
homage there to uh the original as they
as they call it
uh another shotgun this from the from
the the way the front
from the cocking tube where the cocking
tube is mated to the barrel
i always feel daft trying to id real
weapons from this game because i'm
not always based on real ones but
surprisingly often they are
that appears to be our old friend the
ithaca 37 shotgun
except that it's got an ejection port on
the side of it um and the ithaca
both loads and ejects from the bottom of
the gun so that's a i'm not even gonna
call it an error because
this is not in any way meant to be
realistic as to why it's in the game in
that sawn off configuration
i think that's got to be an alien's
homage
because of hicks with his antique pump
action ithaca
that's my guess anyway it could just be
the model that they chose
another one of these fascinating
magazine fed
rocket launchers where we somehow stuff
a load of rounds in the front of it
and then we can fire them out in
sequence and needless to say as you tell
from my smug grin that's that's not how
these work
although as i think i mentioned last
time there was a system called metal
storm
that did work in that way with
electrical ignition
and superimposed loaded munitions
clearly that's not what they're going
for here this is just
a cartoon bazooka so i think this is
meant to be it's clearly meant to be a
us bazooka it's got a
the white star on the side of it and the
name of it with liberty in the name
it's meant to be a bazooka probably the
either the m1a1
or the m20 super bazooka one of those
with a
with the sort of cage protector on the
back of the of the launcher and the big
blocky pistol grip with a stirrup
guard on it uh again we've got recoil
modeled here so it
implies power with a with a weapon when
something recoils like that but
neither recoilless weapons nor rocket
launchers which is what this is
they shouldn't be recoiling both systems
equal out the recoil
by the way they're designed so they
shouldn't shouldn't really move to the
rear
at all
our old friend the milker grenade
launcher has made another appearance
here in
essentially warner brothers style now
this works pretty much like it does in
all other games
with the rotary magazine drum although
the grenades in this kind of
tumble out of the muzzle in a weird sort
of way it's almost like it's a grenade
thrower rather than a grenade launcher
breaks open like the real thing
kind of functions like the real thing
has the usual controls on it that don't
really do anything
for team fortress and the strictly
cosmetic
iron sights i'm kind of intrigued by how
you can just
randomly insert the grenades vaguely in
the direction of the gun
and they go in the right place even
though he's not turning the cylinder or
putting them in different chambers
you just just shove them in close it up
crack on
right well this is apparently an
unremarkable sticky bomb launcher which
i think has to be deliberate sarcasm
because there is no such thing needless
to say as a sticky bomb launcher and so
any such weapon would by itself be
remarkable
and from thence the humor arose i
suspect interestingly this
looks like it's based on the chinese qlz
87
semi-automatic grenade launcher which is
much longer than this in real life but
has a similar
drum magazine type arrangement i'd
suspect that's what they're going for
but it could be an original design
it's got a weird weird design drum mag
very short barrel
loading is affected not by replacing the
magazine or by loading rounds into the
magazine
but by uh molesting the weapon
repeatedly until it refills
by cranking the cocking handle back and
forth i i like the idea of
a different explosive weapon so the
little bombs have spikes on them they
stick into things they blow up it does
what it says on the tin
i'm gonna have to pause there because
we've got a brief sighting of
not a gun of a claymore not a claim or
in fact but a a two-handed sword
clearly based on the one from braveheart
which was also not a claymore
um we won't go too far down that rabbit
hole
a fun thing a fun weapon to incorporate
into a first person shooter
i'd heard that it was in the game but
it's the first time i've seen it
well we had some variants effectively of
this last time the mini gun which is
what it is really i've got one behind me
again but this is the vanilla version i
gather
it's got the extended flash hider
effectively is what that is which you'll
see on some mountings of the minigun
but others will won't have it depends
what sort of vehicle aircraft they're
mounted in what sort of
pod thing they're in it's got the a huge
ammo drum thing on it which looks more
like something like the vulcan or the
avenger cannon the 20 millimeter or the
30 millimeter
big brothers of the minigun which is
called the minigun because it's a mini
balkan aircraft cannon because it really
isn't that many but it's mini relative
to a 20 millimeter cannon
so there's no there's no absolutely
nothing i can say realism wise because
it's just not in any way it's not meant
to be
it's based ultimately on i guess the
chain gun from doom
in that most miniguns in games could
probably trace their inspiration to that
which was erroneously called the chain
gun
is actually a type of gatling gun it's a
trope
of video game gunnery at this point
[Music]
right this is a surprise the classic
i'm not sure in what way it's a classic
but this is a heckler and [ __ ] g36 or
very
close to it well not very close it's
like a sort of
funko pop version of a g36
and also for some reason it's a sniper
type rifle so it's got an exaggerated
long barrel
what is actually a battlefield optic
with a red dot sight and a
low magnification optical sight
unexpectedly
it's not semi-automatic it's somehow a
bolt action although i don't think i've
seen a bolt on it as yet
for some reason it has what looks like a
picatinny
rail under the carrying handle where it
wouldn't be
super helpful although you can in a real
gun remove that whole carrying handle
assembly
but the real gun has a cocking handle
in that position that flicks out to the
side and you use it to [ __ ] the gun
but this doesn't need that because it
has a magical bolt handle somewhere
i've just also noticed the front sight
has a big old fashioned
ramp foresight on it that cannot
possibly function because there's a load
of gun in the way of it
and no rear sight but the front sight is
below the line of the hand guys
it's kind of blowing my mind slightly so
i'm going to stop
that looks an awful lot like a jar of
piss am i am i watching
postal 3 or am i watching team fortress
2
okay we have a crossbow not something
that we
do much of here but we do have a good
collection of
sporting crossbows from the medieval
period the tudor period
stewart period and a handful of military
type crossbows as well
the closest equivalent that i can offer
you for what we're seeing
here the crusaders crossbow which is
clearly despite the name
actually quite a high-tech bit of kit
closest thing we've got would be
big joe this is big joe who looks not a
million miles away from
the crusaders crossbow i suppose now for
those of you who are wondering what does
it shoot
quite lightweight steel and aluminium
bolts
and the heads on these are like type 16
medieval arrowheads so a surprising real
world parallel
i guess um i mean you have to squint
pretty hard to see the the similarity
but it's the closest thing we've got so
let's see how this thing works
right well that's not a crossbow is it
that's a gun with a crossbow prod stuck
to it
it's not cocking in any way there's not
even a string
it's it's not a crossbow it's more like
chewie's bowcaster
although i think that those those
crossbow like protrusions on that are
meant to do something
there's nothing on this that seems to
function it's even got a gun barrel
on it this thing now there are forms of
bow that have a
a supporting tube for the for the for
the bolts
that's like a barrel but um yeah this is
this is something else
[Music]
this is actually a very good
representation
of a nagant model 1895
revolver which is what i'm just offering
up to the screen to just assure myself
of
how accurate it is now you'll notice how
lovely and shiny and well made this is
this is from the the actual nagant
contract
before the russian production line was
up and fully up and running
a number of these were made for russia
in belgium
by the company that originated the
design so it's a little bit
fancy compared to your typical account
revolver
but it works the same way with a loading
gate on the right-hand side
and you just load and extract there's a
there's a rod extractor here that you
pull out swivel and use to knock out
your empties that would be a bit of a
faff in the game so they've departed
back to the more usual way of doing
things
by having a swing out cylinder but
there's no mechanism on this gun
or in the model in the game for actually
swinging out the cylinder it should be
fixed and it should be loaded through a
loading gate so it's kind of nice and
reassuring to see a real gun
at last
[Applause]
sentry guns are real or at least
nearly real we have the technology
already the the ai software the hardware
to identify track and fire upon
targets we have it we could do it right
now just like aliens just like this
we don't do it typically because there's
that fear of removing the human from the
loop
because what we do have are remote
weapon stations and
unmanned ground vehicles ugvs that are
increasingly actually seeing service and
with a controller
you can use those weapons against the
enemy what you can't do
is have it programmed to attack on its
own where team fortress really does
depart from
reality is to have to have two mini guns
on any kind of system like this i think
is excessive
the ammunition requirements would be too
high the weight would be tremendous
so this is something we're going to see
become increasingly real in future
remote weapon stations with rockets and
guns absolutely
we'll probably also see systems that
will identify
identify track and ask permission to
fire
and then permission will be given or the
fire button will remain a human
activated button but we are almost there
and then we have this thing which is i
swear this has been included just to
break my mind there's no physical way as
if you didn't already know this
that this thing could work so it's yet
another pump action shotgun
it's got yet another non-functional
hammer on the back of it another
non-functional
bolt on the left side which really ought
to be on the right
we load it by kind of wafting underneath
it
implying that we're loading a tube
magazine underneath and yes it has a
drum magazine
and the drum magazine is mounted just
under the muzzle and i don't think i
need to explain
why that's not in any way realistic
join us again next time for another one
of these if you'd like more in the way
of
firearms content we've got a series over
on the royal armouries channel
featuring me as well if you'd like to
support the work that we do here at the
royal armouries with this
collection of stuff behind me you can
find links in the description but
otherwise i'll see you again next time
[Music]
you